unusual admission caught on body camera
video after police arrived to the scene
of a deadly shooting almost immediately
the suspect admits he's the shooter
I'm right here nobody else I'm right
here on July 21st police officers
responded to a shooting in Parma Ohio
about 20 minutes outside of Cleveland
[Music]
say that again
204. all right let me try this front
[Applause]
on the front doors officials say 26 year
old Julius Sanders was shot and killed
at an apartment complex on the city's
South Side Body camera video shows
officers entering the scene
foreign
the hallway here uh units responding
front doors got a pen in it
let me just wash the stairwell
probably above
video shows an officer climbed the steps
to find 25 year old suspect David Grant
at the top grams can be heard saying
quote I'm the shooter
after that police take Grant into
custody what's going on come on come on
I'm alone
foreign
thank you
blood Shooters in custody one Mile's
down
you're not going anywhere as more first
responders arrive on the scene Grant
again admits that he's the shooter here
I got a glove you could probably use it
as a chest seal
I'm just trying to spread it up yeah I'm
good with him
wide open
yeah
I'm right here nobody else I'm right
here Grant is then escorted from the
scene the firearm was down on the ground
there yes sir to me is right there
yep
all right
officials later confirmed that Grant and
Sanders knew each other and that before
the shooting a fight broke out Grant has
since been charged with first degree
murder reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie